LOOKINGING TO PUT A LITTLE
BIT BETTER OF A DEFENSIVE
PERFORMANCE IN AGAIN TONIGHT
GOES FOR THE ATTACK HERE AND
OF THE ICE, JUST A LITTLEY
TAVARES. AS THE LEAFS GET
SCORES!
[ Horn sounding ] THAT
GLOVE TUCKED INTO THE BODY.
TAVARES WITH THE HEAD UP AND
HE TIPSKICKS IT --
RUBINS PENALTY.
13 POINTS -- OH!
DeBRINCAT UNABLE TO GET THAT
ONE UP A
CENTERING PASS SCORES!
[ Hor PASSENGER
THERE.
WATCHING INSTEAD
>>
CREDITED WITH EIGHT GAMER.
LANKINEN.
>> Chris: KANE AND
DeBRINCAT.
STEEVES IN FRONT.
ENGVALL, SHOT.THE QUICK
TURNAROUND FROM A TIGHT SCORES D
CHICAGO DRAWS WITHIN TWO.
>> Greg: A REALLY GOOD
BUT MRAZEK CLEARLYERIOD GOAL INE
FIRST SPEED TO THE OUTSIDE.
CHIP PASS ACROSS.
NO WASTED TIME ON THAT ONE
HIS SHOT SCORES!T.E BRING CAT OE
THROUGH TRAFFIC.
IT'S THREE STRAIGHT FOR
DIDN'T LOOK LIKE HE GOT A
PIECE OF IT.
THIS TIME MRAZEK WAS WAY T T
AND THE LEAFS GET THER, CHRIS, S
NOT YOUR BUILDING AND IT'S
UP ALONG THE GLASS JUS